jeremy corbyn says the labour party
won't be all about message discipline
but at this event they had a couple of
key themes and they really did
hammer them home hard so look at what
greeted the delegates as they went into
the hall straight talking honest
politics those are
big big old letters and they're in
capitals not a great deal of subtlety
there and there was no subtlety about
the way that jeremy corbyn returned
to his key refrain again again and then
a couple times more with feeling
i want a kinder more caring politics
politics
that's kinder so let's put those values
back
into politics the kinder more caring
world let us build
a kinder politics a kinder politics a
more
caring society you got that uh well i
think so to be fair we
did not anticipate that jeremy corbyn
was going to be a master of speechcraft
stagecraft if you
like uh he's feeling his way this is all
new from his point of view
uh the transitions were pretty clunky as
they were indeed at his tu sp
speech not long ago let me say something
about national security
i want to say a bit more about how we
develop our policy
and saying a bit more about how we
develop our policy is not exactly a
message for
beyond the hall this is a particular bug
bearer of mine
but seriously seriously seriously
seriously i would prefer that jeremy
corbyn had done without the jokes which
are not his forte
and just focused on policy where he's uh
much stronger
if we look at policy he sets the bar
high as you would expect of a
leader of the opposition we have got to
be clear
about where our objectives are okay so
let's look at clarity
on the issue of trident for example that
he says personally he would scrap
but in developing that our policy
through the review we must make sure
that all the jobs and skills of everyone
in every aspect of the defense industry
are fully protected and fully utilized
so you get rid of trident
and yet you protect defense jobs as the
unions of course want
i'm really not sure how one would go
about that and
it sounds suspiciously like trying to
have your cake
and eat it too what about on the key
central
issue of austerity you're talking about
the tories here they expect us to
believe
there is no alternative to cutting jobs
slashing public services vandalizing the
national health service
cutting junior doctors pay reducing care
for the elderly
destroying the hopes of young people for
a college education
or putting university graduates into
massive debt
now the language as you'd expect is
quite emotive but the thrust of what
he's saying is that the tories argue you
have to do things like cutting back on
the public sector cutting back on public
sector pay making sure graduates pay
uh big fees uh and the rest of it
but the election suggests that actually
it's not just the tourists it's quite
a lot of voters who agree with that
argument as well who
or who have bought into it so the
challenge for jeremy corbyn and labour
is to show
how how they think that
they could do things differently the big
plus for jeremy corbyn is his whole
manner and demeanor is so
different to other senior politicians
this at the end
uh he's clapping the audience as much as
they are clapping him he always looks a
bit awkward there's no showboating
nothing grandiose
about this labour leader at all a really
warm atmosphere generally in the hall
and he would hope that some of that
might have spilled over to those
watching outside too